but what is aside from hey you trust the
angel what is it a criteria for a
founders fund investment if you had to
think about it yeah it's a great
question because since we are so stage
agnostic and sector agnostic it's not
like I can say oh we're looking for
Ceres bees in health space or whatever
like you mean that's not a thing from
and this is where we are all individuals
and everybody at founders fund can kind
of run their own strategy and we
encourage everybody at founders fund to
run their own strategy and those could
be very different
like Sian has a very different strategy
different than me that's great
like I don't know which one of those is
gonna be right I know sign is
ridiculously good like that'll that'll
make us some money and I think that I
can do this stuff too but for me
personally I'm looking for anything that
I think is extremely important for the
world that has an existing moat right
not a oh if they do this and this and
this then it'll be really good but
something that has an existing mode of
some type that can be earlier late
unpack the moat concept a bit I mean we
know what the term means but in today's
world give us some examples of moats
maybe starting with that slide where the
most yeah I mean so stem Centrex we
didn't need we didn't an angel invest in
some centric so let's be clear we our
first check was like 35 you know around
35 million that was at a 300 million
dollar valuation this was a company that
had already had shown efficacy not in
humans yet that was the next day's and
that's what got them the big price tag
but they had shown efficacy in mice and
we really dug into their mouse model and
thought that that was gonna work in
other words we had never seen a company
that would actually cure solid tumors in
small cell lung cancer before we'd never
seen that and there was that was proven
yeah to us so that's a clear example of
an existing moat SpaceX okay when we
invested in SpaceX in 2008 they had had
three rocket launches all failures but
hey at least they had built a company
that could have a rocket launch right
good luck trying to clone that so one of
the things I like to say and not in you
know press or whatever is like anything
that a Y Combinator company can clone in
three days where I'm probably not going
to be interested in good luck trying to
clone SpaceX right like Airbnb is
another classic example here we didn't
see it invest in Airbnb it was way to
eat we saw it we
Crudup by not investing but it was way
too easy to clone then doesn't matter
we have no FOMO right I'm not gonna say
oh man we missed out on the air B&B
early stage so that means we shouldn't
do anyone know so we came in and put in
a hundred and fifty million in air B&B
at the two and a half billion dollar
valuation round and that's because we
had seen at that point there is
literally no competition for air B&B we
know we're big investors in lift there's
tons of competition for lifts there's
tons of competition for uber there's
literally no competition for Airbnb in
that regard they have a network effect
going and we say you're solely strong
send anything with Facebook you know
when we put all the money in right I
mean it was so strong so those are just
some examples of what I mean by existing
mode Oscar we actually invested in
pretty stat so Oscar is a health
insurance company on the Affordable Care
Act out of based out of base that
companies based out of New York we
invested in Oscar early and that's
because they had gotten approval to be
on the Affordable Care Act exchange you
know this is not something that any
random startup can do lots of startups
build tech for health companies or tech
for health insurance companies you're
not you can't get the appeal I was
telling people at dinner last night like
to be on the board of this company I had
my you know hole both of my hands
fingerprinted hardcore by a government
official like insurance is so highly
regulated to do that so we'd mess in
that early because they had already
gotten that approval and that's hard to
do